cap learns that Sharon from across the
hall is Sharon Carter Peggy's great
niece even if everyone
is telling you that something wrong
is something right
even if the whole world is telling you
to move
it is your duty
to plant yourself like a tree look them
in the eye and say no
you move this speech was actually
paraphrased from Cap's words to Peter
Parker in the civil war comics in which
Peter Parker starts on team Iron Man but
switches to team cap as we'll see
throughout the film characters will tell
cap to move but he never yields move
Captain move it wasn't here not moving
is kind of a cap thing can you move
no
foreign